another glorious opportunity
and the sound of the thud of
that puck hitting the pad comes
across looked like he was dead to
rights an just gave it away connecting down low
San the again and kept it out of the arabin gets
that sa he sweeps it right off the goal line
right there good play by shatur here's the
chance for Mika and this what a save from Omar
cuz it's sat down for steming on the doorstep
another glorious opportunity and the sound of
the thud of that puck hitting the pad looks
like a wide open at a great reaction there two on
one it's baraby who shoots safe rebound soken got
it there's the athletic ability of sokin on
display as he flashed across to keep this a
two- goal game with his trademark speed pulls
up got the shot through givs in that little
trouble with a wrap around by Blue what a save
by Gibson lunging back to his left and he kept
the rebound out as well now a quick little wrap
around here as Bluer thinks he's got Gibson and
Gibson slams that left arm right along the goal
line and just able to keep the puck out to on
the bouncing p in front for Hy great chance and
a great save by corello oh he had the wide open
side of the net and Corpus does a nice job of
tracking this through an open scene to fagi by
Gam but jump on he's forcing across oh what a
save by Corpus Salo off of that flag as Corpus
Salo comes up with his second big save of the
night and what a kick save by Corpus Salo comes
across look like he was dead to rights plank
off the glass behind the that here's a steal si
in front Mar him scrambles back with the somehow
that stay up oh what to say fck some desperation
mares show passing great save lar what a stop
off W with the left p on a two-on one normally
a shooter that holds the goalie and somehow lar
gets over I mean what a save this is absolutely
spectacular Cen starting the play Leo Carlson
drops Troy Terry back to her feed mon pushed
across and Alex color the Montreal na of was
looking go that was my first goal in a Ducks
uniform how did he make that save two on
one for the Ducks cutting in pass across
what stop who needs a sick when you got that
glub on Tempo robbery on vatrano Sports Center
Line one that was sick and on the play it's
McTavish over the robed by the GL hand of
mono what a stop what an unbelievable stop
despite the for here's grundstrom right to
the side of the met I think Gibson got his
stick on that he he reached back and made
one heck of a stop here Luke de thinks he's
got a sure goal and John Gibson reaches back
with that goal stick makes an incredible
stop look at that off the heel of the goal
stick getting it to Guston now wheeler with
a pass and V he shot a save look and and got
his stick on it unbelievable empet had
the whole net and Lucan wouldn't give up
a desperation dive with the stick wide open
net and lucanet just wouldn't give up on the
play now he turn shoots it rebound oh what a save
by like it it shot on goal rebound right here to
Justin Faulk and what a save there numbers for
St Louis sunquist solder Bloom got there in the
Nick and we mean the nick of time oh my goodness
off the skate off the post and then out of play
that's a great reactionary Save Right There by
solder Blom there's a shot deflection save rebound
diving stopped by har as he robs Paso great save
here and then card dies across there giving his
all to get over there and get that one what a
great save there I think he got it with his head
here they come again nen Hopkins bang bang great
glove save lingren robbed Hyman there a catching
m a beauty by lingren what a save late here in
this second period Kim trying to get there steel
here's a chance lar with a save up Kimber after
a giveaway by the Flames D lar forced to make a
big stop and keep this a one goal game battle
with the Predators club that sits above him in
the standings a sliding save by guson well he
gets caught on the first one but how about the
recovery on the second one gives up the juicy
rebound but he slides over makes a Walker save
my goodness it's forer dropping it back save
since per rebound deflected into the quarter
I think the save was made by lingren I think he
stopped it from going in the net Here Comes gel
finds forby oh man a save by quick that's just
a fabulous save just a fabulous save beautiful
pass Crosby Wast no time at all and getting over
there in a hurry was Jonathan Quick Here Comes
crer moving in on the breakway oh he stopped by
elar Ryder was going for a hatrick he put on a
very good move here and he just couldn't Elevate
the puck over the pad butar with a great effort
left pad extended able to take that backhander
away did not play here on Saturday night back
in there tonight there's a save by Backstrom and
another as he robbed Matthew Phillips twice and
here you'll see a perfect example of Stellar goal
tending Phillips once Phillips twice Everly steals
it centers what a save by Demco on ell tolvanen
loses the Pucket centered oh what a save by Demco
on Tolen came right across the crease Everly to
Tolman and then Demco with the left pad kept it
out